hello welcome to science breakthroughs
from science mission I'm sadashiva pie
I'm going to discuss couple of
breakthrough papers published in the
week of june 9th let's start first we
are going to discuss a paper published
by bernard lantern in m bio on the role
of bacterial biofilms in atherosclerotic
plaques why is this paper so important
not much is known about the role of
bacteria in the atherosclerotic plaque
formation father show the presence of
bacterial biofilms in the plaques
authors also identify conditions that
disturb biofilms leading to plug
destabilization authors analyzed 15
ethra sclerotic expands by pcr and found
16s ribosomal RNA from bacteria in all
of them density gradient gel
electrophoresis on Phi of the plaques
revealed the presence of common and
uncommon 16s ribosomal RNA in all the
five clocks confocal images of the you
bacterial 16s ribosomal RNA gene
sequence in the carotid arterial plaque
showed the presence of gene as shown
here in red other show in vitro culture
that the plaques could be disrupted in
the presence of increasing amounts of
iron where does the iron come from I
income from transferring in the blood
and in the presence of norepinephrine
plus could be disrupted releasing
bacterial enzymes that might cause
damage to the surrounding tissue and
released plugs could also block the
arteries leading to heart attack or
stroke authors did not toward any data
that said this happens in vivo
nevertheless they conclusively show the
presence of bacterial biofilms in the
blocks next let's look at another paper
published by
yes wall in science authors provide
scientific proof for motor function
revival after stroke why is this paper
so important brain regenerative
capability and recovery after stroke is
limited treatment options like
rehabilitation have at only minimal
success other show that sequential
treatment of nerve growth promoting
antibody therapy followed by
rehabilitative training almost
completely restored skill for limb
functions of the cortical strokes in
adult rats here is the data to support
their claim using photo thrombosis or
thurs induced blood vessel blockade by
multiple micro thrombi which destroyed
more than ninety percent of the
sensorimotor cortex of adult rats rats
were then treated with intrathecal anti
no goei or control a Driver d for two
weeks in addition they trained the rats
intensively in skill four-limbed
reaching either simultaneously with
antibody application that is parallel
group or during till two weeks after
antibody treatment that is sequential
true when the growth-enhancing anti
no-go a treatment was followed by the
rehabilitative training that a
sequential group and you must improve
their performance from day 16 post row
and the skilled reaching abilities
almost completely recurved to pre stroke
level significantly better than all
other groups others looked at different
sprouting patterns of particle spinal
fibers from epsilon cortex of different
groups their result suggests that the
recovery of radford limb function after
stroke in the sequential group
originates from extensive and precise
reinnervation of the stroke dinner
weighted spinal hammock or by mid line
crossing fibers from intact motor cortex
anti novo parallel enemas also showed
growth but nerve fibers had extensive
branching and aberrant termination
others come from these results using
various stroke and spinal cord engineer
models that are not shown here that
relate midline crossing corticospinal
fibers to functional outcome so this
paper provides experimental proof for
sequential rehabilitation therapy
following stroke for a better outcome
thank you for watching science
breakthroughs from science mission